- Well, we have an audience full of people
who have been inspired by Olivia
to take some gutsy chances.
But before we hear them, I
feel like we should share ours.
I'll share, I was kind
of sharing a little bit
of mine in the break,
but I get tattoos, well, not all of them,
but a lot of them are when
not great things happen.
And I do it because I like
the reminder that I made it.
And it, sometimes things seem so big
in your world at that moment
and you feel like you're not
gonna make it, and then you do.
And so, usually that's
when I get the tattoo.
One of my favorites is on
my middle finger. (laughs)
(Olivia laughs)
Yeah.
And it says DC and it's,
'cause somebody made me feel,
and I don't know, I hope
you never experience this
or haven't, but, 'cause I do
think we've progressed a little
in this industry, but yeah,
people can be very mean.
I mean, they can be just vicious
and it's, you know, if
you're not successful,
how they want you to be
and doing what you want.
And it's usually their shortcomings.
- [Olivia] Sure.
- And I mean, just someone was so vicious
and I was so tired of sitting in a room
where men just made me feel like (beep)
and then I was like, you know what, nope.
I actually had the guts to finally say,
and I was in my twenties, you know,
and I started at 19, so
I was, it took a minute,
but I finally said like, you know what?
I was like, "Actually, I
think this is about you
and I think this is about,"
and I just totally said everything
I've ever wanted to say in that moment.
So that's one of my favorite tattoos.
- Wow, that's beautiful.
- Yeah.
I hope you don't go through that, but,
what's one of yours?
- Oh my gosh.
My gutsy story after that beautiful story,
mine's gonna sound so silly.
- [Kelly] No.
- I know.
- No, it won't, make it lighter.
- [Olivia] Okay, okay.
- I was a little heavy for daytime.
(Olivia laughs)
Yeah, yeah.
- For daytime.
You know, I was thinking, coming up here,
because we're at 30
Rock, we're in New York.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The second time I ever
performed in my career was on SNL.
And I was 18 years old.
(audience cheers)
- Wow.
- And I was so, which is incredible,
I mean, what an honor,
but I was terrified.
- Yes, and it's so late.
- [Olivia] It's so late.
- Yes, for a vocalist.
- Yes, and it's so live.
- [Kelly] Uh huh.
- Yeah, per the name.
And I just remember being terrified
and being in my dressing room
and being like, "I don't
know if I deserve to be here.
This is terrifying."
But did it anyway.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That was brave of me.
But not quite as beautiful
as your story.
- Whatever.
Don't do that.
That is very brave.
I've done SNL.
It's a little nerveracking.
- It's scary, yeah.
- Yeah.